and one of the consensus is actually
from think-tanks on the left and the
right was their help to buy was a bad
idea and is a bad idea
because when you've got massive pent-up
demand and still contains constrained
supply if you give people the ability to
buy with even more money funded by
taxpayers prices are just going to lap
loans which is what happened so the
margins that the big help to buy only
helps you if you buy a new build
so what help to buy did and its cost
like 20 to 30 billion so far is it just
massively increased the profits of the
big house builders who were then giving
loads of campaign donations but they
weren't didn't actually end up building
more homes the big house builders are
still building far fewer homes than they
were before the financial crisis and
we've have very few small builders now
because they were all wiped out by the
financial crisis and they haven't been
able to get a foot in the door they
can't get hold of land because the big
guys have got it all sewn up that's why
it is as I say and oligopoly some people
would say it's a cartel which is
actually illegal the big house builders
would deny that I think there is very
compelling evidence now which the big
house builders deny your honor a cartel
in actual restrictive practices that's
why I call in the book for a full
Competition Commission inquiry at
looking at you know where we actually
examine if the market is operating
properly I don't think it is the house
Lords Economic Affairs Select Committee
the chairman Michael Forsyth read home
truths they're now doing an inquiry into
house building industry I gave evidence
to it and I and I repeated that
recommendation that we see now
Competition Commission inquiry just to
get numbers on the concentration on the
house building industries is pretty
difficult at the moment they're being
very coy about their actual output so
we'll see if the House of Lords takes up
that recommendation and what happens but
help to buy is a great for a short term
headline if you're a Chancellor and it's
good for some of the people that it
helps right but a lot of the people that
it helps and I've made documentaries for
dispatches about this have ended up in
lashed together substandard new-build
homes because the big house builders
know they're a captive audience because
they're using help to buy right and so
you end up with this situation where all
that's happened is that help the buyers
pushed up the price of increasingly bad
quality new build homes for those who
can get access to help to buy and
they're like 95% of homebuyers who can't
get access to help to buy have to face
even more high prices and then you and
then you highlighted the bonuses that
these chairmen will get are these
companies insane and it's it's in the
tens of million mind people making money
again if they've done something
incredible when brought new technology
online you know I'm a capitalist I like
profit but these are like mediocre
executives overseeing badly run
companies with ghastly customer service
records I'm looking at you persimmon and
they're using as I said technology
that's been around for you know
available to anybody you know go to a
builder's yard and all the secrets are
there yeah talk to her any number of
blokes propping up bars around the UK
they tell you how to build a house and
yet they're making bonuses of like tens
of millions of pounds a year that is a
clear signal the market is not working
right
I like capitalism but capitalism needs
to work and what we got here with the
house building industry isn't capitalism
it's a grotesque Distortion
that's giving capitalism a bad name and
is working only for the firms and not
for the customers and broad society
[Music]